tuvo el momento de la economía en
nuestro programa directo américa ya está
lista en el estudio daniel hablando
honda ni bienvenida a feliz mañana del
lunes comenzamos con siete de las
economías más grandes del mundo que
amenazan con sancionar a rusia por todo
este el tema político que está pasando y
las tensiones militares daniela sí señor
ramón muy buenos días descansa el fin de
semana descanse el fin de semana la
verdad sí muy bien yo también lo he
reparador sí señor pues mira los
ministros de finanzas del g7 emitieron
un comunicado conjunto en el que
advierten a rusia que habrá serias
consecuencias en caso de que decidiera
eventualmente invadir a rusia a ucrania
este grupo está conformado por las
grandes economías occidentales que son
canadá francia alemania italia japón
reino unido y nada más y nada menos que
eeuu pues washington y sus aliados ya
han dado luces de en que podrían
consistir estos castigos en lo que han
llamado la madre de las sanciones por
ejemplo raúl excluir a rusia del sistema
financiero swift que permite transferir
dinero de un banco a otro en todo el
mundo pero de lo que no se ha hablado
mucho desde las consecuencias económicas
que también tendrían en respuesta de
moscú rusia es el mayor proveedor de
energía de la unión europea cerca del 40
por ciento de las importaciones de gas
provienen de ese país así como casi un
tercio del petróleo entonces ante todo
esto daniela como amanecieron las bolsas
vamos con los indicadores raúl pues
bastante mal bastante nerviosos están en
el mercado los mercados del mundo
abrieron la semana ha tenidos de rojo a
medida que aumentan pues estos temores
sobre una eventual invasión rusa a
ucrania euro para acá entre el 2 y el 3
por ciento y los sectores más afectados
son los de viajes banca y automóviles el
asia-pacífico cerró mixto sólo con
australia subiendo en una jornada
también generalizada de pérdidas y
veremos qué pasa también con wall street
que nada raro que inicia también a la
baja vamos a ver qué pasa y lo que vamos
a eeuu le gustan los aguacates daniela a
mí me encanta la boca te podría
desayunar almorzar y cenar aguacate yo
también soy como usted pero le pregunta
entonces porque suspendieron las ventas
de aguacates mexicanos en eeuu
raúl lo están haciendo hasta nuevo aviso
después de que eeuu descubriera que uno
de sus funcionarios en méxico estaba
siendo amenazado a través de mensajes en
su celular los aguacates son las más
recientes víctimas raúl de las batallas
territoriales entre cárteles de droga en
méxico y cada vez crecen más los casos
de extorsión hacia los productores de
michoacán que es el único estado
mexicano totalmente autorizado para
exportar a eeuu y que tiene que ver
entonces le pregunto con el superbowl
que fue ya la final ayer el ayer domingo
que por supuesto vamos a hablarlo con
juan pieles más adelante en deporte
entonces él preguntó qué tiene que ver
bueno fue una simple coincidencia pero
mire la coincidencia esta sorpresiva
suspensión se produjo justo en la
víspera del superbowl de este domingo
que a su vez es la mayor oportunidad de
ventas en el año para los productores de
aguacates mexicanos en la unión
americana aunque todos los que se iban a
comer ayer ya estaban en eeuu de hecho
la asociación mexicana de exportadores y
empacadores de aguacate tuvo su propio
anuncio en el juego que mostraba como
los fanáticos resolvían diferencias
aparentemente violentas mientras
disfrutaban de un guacamole
diferencias con un cien por ciento de
bueno este lunes entran en vigencia las
medidas en turquía para frenar la
inflación realmente estas medidas si
logran frenar la daniela pues primero
digamos de cuánto la inflación es del 50
por ciento anual es decir año frente al
2021 en este momento como no lo hacían
los precios hace 20 años no subían todo
eso raúl y el presidente receptor y
perdón anunció que a partir de hoy se
reducirá el impuesto al valor agregado
del 8 por ciento al 1 por ciento en
alimentos básicos que van desde el arroz
y la carne hasta las frutas y las
verduras pero el problema de la
inflación va más allá hay comerciantes
que se quejan de que sus energías son
más caras inclusive el alquiler de sus
locales y cuál es la causante del alza
de estos precios entonces más muchos
culpan de la inflación a la poco
ortodoxa política económica de erdogán
insiste en que hay que bajar las tasas
de interés para fomentar el consumo y de
esta manera que la economía mejore pero
en el resto del mundo lo que están
haciendo como lo hemos venido informando
acá los bancos centrales es precisamente
lo contrario bajar las tasas de interés
para detener el impacto inflacionario
que han dejado esta clase de estímulos
durante la pandemia le pregunta entonces
la cifra del día raúl esa cifra es una
cifra que me enorgullece como colombiana
quiero decir le vamos a ver la 650
millones de tallos de flores que exportó
colombia para asar san valentín el 80
por ciento se fue para estados unidos y
el resto de otros países como canadá
países bajos reino unido japón españa
rusia y polonia dan y gracias entonces
por toda la información esta cifra el
día y feliz día de san valentín también
en muchos países como por ejemplo en
venezuela del amor elemental que juegan
pilas ya decía que no que solamente
solamente el amor y
metida vamos a ver el reportaje del día
a danny